afuera de palacio nacional el 14 de
febrero de 2020 un grupo de mujeres
realizó una encendida protesta adentro
una mujer periodista y activista también
alzaba la voz allí afuera están gritando
mujeres porque porque llevamos más de
250 feminicidios en lo que va del 2020
más de 300 homicidios si hablamos en
general porque no existe así como existe
una fiscalía antisecuestro especializada
para ese tema porque no existe una
fiscalía especializada para el tema del
femicidio ese día verónica villalvazo
mejor conocida como frida guerrera cobró
más notoriedad en su labor de difusión
de casos de feminicidios a raíz de eso
el hostigamiento hacia ella aumentó
aunque en realidad lo ha padecido desde
de amenazas de que voy a ser el próximo
feminicidio de que mi cabeza ni siquiera
voy a ver darme cuenta en qué momento me
la van a aportar siempre que hay un
feminicidio frida busca estar ahí un
ejemplo es el caso de victoria pamela
salas martínez una joven cruelmente
asesinada por su pareja es una mujer
como pocas hay de verdad yo creo que
nadie nadie en la vida va a ser como
ella ella se ha encargado de
de visibilizar todos esos casos que han
estado en el olvido porque así nos dejan
enterrados psicóloga de formación cuida
sabe cómo acercarse a las víctimas
primero cuando yo me pagan frente de una
familia tengo que hablar entrevista del
dolor
y darle contención que lloren que se
enojen y después viene la empatía y
cuando ellos ya lloraron y ya se
enojaron entonces yo siempre hago esa
pregunta ahora presenta me la y dime
cómo era porque yo no la voy a conocer
qué sentiste cuando te embarazas te y
entonces ella sonriendo a pesar de las
amenazas
frida está decidida a continuar su labor